man redet immer so viel drüber da kann
ich den selbst man möglichst schmerzfrei
machen und all so was ist wenn die
sollte viel mehr wert darauf gelegt
werden den zu verhindern
[Musik]
wir starten jetzt mit der wichtigsten
frage dieser diskussion um mit der
ersten frage von 13 fragen sollte jeder
mensch ein recht auf organisierte
sterbehilfe haben wenn ihr jetzt sagt ja
dann geht er einen schritt ins grüne
kätzchen und wenn ihr seid knallen nicht
jeder oder keiner dann geht er einen
schritt ins gelbe kiste
[Musik]
habt ihr euch schon mal mit dem thema
sterbehilfe befasst das ding ist nämlich
rund 100.000 menschen versuchen sich
jährlich in deutschland umzubringen
ungefähr 10.000 menschen von denen
sterben am ende tatsächlich das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat jetzt
beschlossen in deutschland hat jeder
mensch einen anspruch auf sterbehilfe
egal ob kerngesund oder schwer krank
doch wer entscheidet final ob jemand
sterben darf oder nicht darüber
diskutieren wir heute hier bei 310
fragen und für euch heißt es ab jetzt
wenn ihr eine aussage der anderen seite
zustimmt dann geht er einen schritt auf
sie zu und wenn ihr der aussage nicht
zustimmt oder richtig sauer seit und
diese wut ausdruck verleihen wollt dann
geht er einen schritt zurück und ich
will heute natürlich das ist mein ziel
euch möglichst weit hier ins kompromiss
feld bringen und deswegen umso mehr ihr
euch bewegt umso besser für mich
brigitte ich möchte mit dir gerne
anfangen du bist ja mitglied in einem
sterbehilfe verein in was für einem
moment kommt man auf den gedanken da
trete ich jetzt mal ein das ist bei mir
eine ganz persönliche erfahrung und zwar
hat das mit meiner mutter zu tun die vor
drei jahren einen sehr sehr schlimmen
sturz hatte und es kam dann so dass sie
nach sechs wochen querschnittgelähmt war
und als 89 jährige frau die ihr ganzes
leben lang selbstständig war bis zu dem
sturz konnte sie das nicht verkaufen sie
wollte sterben außerdem hatte sie
schmerzen die offenbar nicht
therapierbar war
und ich habe ihr vorgeschlagen in ihrer
verzweiflung dass ich sehe wenn sie das
möchte in die schweiz begleitet zur
sterbehilfe ich denke das ist eine
anmaßung
über das leben eines anderen menschen zu
bestimmen jeder mensch hat das recht
über sein leben und seinen tod selbst zu
bestimmen ja ich bin dann mit meiner
mutter zusammen in diesem verein
eingetreten meine mutter ist ohne
sterbehilfe verstorben damals die zeit
hat uns überholt ich bin aber drin
geblieben weil ich das für mich auch
sehr wichtig finde eventuell gegebenen
fall in anspruch zu nehmen ich würde
auch total interessieren wie seht ihr
das eigentlich also es euch das wichtig
diese option zu haben ihren tod
selbstbestimmt zu können schreibt man
die kommentare hier steht jetzt auf der
anderen seite wollt ihr euch dazu
positionieren würde dir einen schritt
auf brigitte zu gehen die frage ist ob
es ein recht auf organisationen gibt die
sozusagen ein beim suizid assistieren
und das heißt ja dass jeder dieses recht
in jeder situation annehmen kann und das
verfassungsgericht hat ja auch keine
neue rechtslage geschaffen sondern nur
klargestellt was unsere rechtslage ist
und auch immer hier war vor 2015 nämlich
dass suizid bei uns straffrei ist anders
als den niederlanden oder österreich
dass die beihilfe zum suizid straftat
und dass jeder geben damit auch dabei
essen darf wir haben ihn nur nicht oder
das wollte der gesetzgeber mit diesem §
2 117 jahre unterbinden der wollte ja
nirgends selbstbestimmung einschränken
sondern wollte menschen schützen vor
sehr unseriösen sterbehelfer die wir
hier ja eine stelle für organisationen
die im geschäftsmäßig professionell bei
für suizid oder dann vielleicht
irgendwann auch tötung auf verlangen
anbieten sehe ich einmal die große
gefahr dass eben patienten oder menschen
die an sterbewunsch äußern nicht
wirklich gut geschaut wird ob dafür
etwas anderes dahinter steht ist er auch
darum geht so nicht mehr leben zu wollen
philipp du mich das nicht selbst
entscheiden wann du stirbst also quasi
genau der kontrast zu brigitte warum
wenn man sich die frage stellt woher das
leben kommt habe ich einfach klasse
erfahrungen gemacht dass es da
vielleicht doch jemand gibt der uns das
leben gegeben hat und dass wir nicht die
berechtigung haben zu sagen okay das
leben ist jetzt vorbei ich habe selber
einen tumor auf der brust und wären
schon ganz viele leute vorgeschlagen
dass ich ja auch mehr gedanken machen
sollte ob die eventuell sterbehilfe in
anspruch nehmen soll ich bin aber der
meinung dass das leben lang vorbei ist
wenn gott es will weil ich daran glaube
dass man gibt er uns geschaffen hat und
der auch ein plan für uns hat und das
auch in die hand nehmen sollte man das
leben vorbei ist das ist meine dritte
krebsdiagnose die letzten male konnte
ich kaum laufen ich weiß momentan auch
überhaupt nicht und diesmal geht es mir
gut kannst du dich noch an den moment
erinnern wo du die diagnose bekommen
hast wie hast du darauf reagiert oder
war im dezember mit dem arzt einen
computerbildschirm und da bin ich denn
so ein krasses loch gefallen weil ich
wusste ich wusste gar nicht wirklich was
krebs ist und hab mich irgendwann meine
nachbarin erinnert in der hand brauchen
die hat krebs gehabt und ich krieg das
jetzt und ich wusste überhaupt nicht
mehr weiter also ziemlich ist die welt
zusammengebrochen
ich konnte mich gar nicht umgehen und du
sagst quasi deswegen bist du gegen einen
selbstbestimmten tod zumindest bei dir
weil du dein leben dann vielleicht sogar
schon beendet hat das so man das nie
genau wissen kann wie so ein colour fall
also ich habe danach sogar meine zweite
krebsdiagnose ist es auch meine mutter
soll niemand den leichenwagen holen als
im krankenwagen weil es mir so schlecht
geht ich habe die zeit auch teilweise
ausgeblendet weil es mir wirklich so
schlecht denkt da hätte hätte ich
wahrscheinlich schon sterbehilfe in
anspruch nehmen können vielleicht sogar
neben zugestimmt und 60 aktionen gegeben
hätte und jetzt stehe ich hier das drei
jahre heerenveen jetzt gut und mein arzt
sagt wie es was da passiert gibt es
wieder fit geworden und von daher sehe
ich schon es gibt da noch mehr zunehmen
und erinnern was sagt ihr dazu findet
ihr einen schritt auf philipp zu gehen
ja
du bist stehen geblieben ich verstehe
deine worte und die berühren einen
natürlich total aber ich glaube heute
die größte gefahr ist da quasi dass du
deine perspektive für andere ein ich
erlebt jeden tag in meiner arbeit was
ist mit menschen macht wenn sich kranke
menschen das leben nehmen müssen weil
sie keinen anderen ausweg sehen und von
der medizin keine hilfe bekommen ich sie
quasi die opfer des suizids neben dem
verstorbenen sowie man dir das recht
dazu ein gestelltes zu machen finde ich
darf es auch die antwort geben die auf
der anderen seite ist nämlich zu sagen
nee ich habe für mich alles ausgeschöpft
was da ist und wie leiden dort
wahrgenommen mit ist halt was sehr
relatives und ich denke da ist die
persönliche freiheit einfach höher zu
bewerten
stimmt zudem zunächst
teilweise also ich kann es mir gut
verstehen wenn man irgendwie so die
erfahrung nicht macht und da jetzt gar
nichts damit anfangen kann er selber nie
in der situation war es nicht erlebt hat
trotzdem glaube ich halt ist für mich so
grundsätzlich so ein bisschen die frage
wer entscheidet über leben und tod geht
es nach dem leben auch weiter und ich
sehe halt ganz klar die gefahr also bei
mir zum beispiel war es so dass ich fast
eine palliative stimmung gemacht hätte
wie jetzt gerade sogar die deutsche
ärzte zeitung geschrieben hat das macht
keinen sinn nur weil meine freunde
gesagt haben ja probier's doch aus und
so und ich sehe eine ganz große gefahr
dass man unter druck gesetzt wird
sterbehilfe in anspruch zu nehmen nur
weil ich mich zum beispiel als last
empfindet und wenn ich wäre auf jeden
fall so ein mensch spielt immer allen
recht machen ich will dann glaube ich
ihm zeit ist vielleicht sogar sagen ja
okay ich nehme es jetzt in anspruch und
daran sind die grenze zu bringen ist
mega schwierig launig ist das finde ich
auch gerade das was du sagst es erstmal
was individuelles ist es ist da nicht
umso gefährlicher jetzt eine normierung
kinder herzustellen was sagen da gibt es
dann die vereine die das patentrezept
anbieten und zu dem thema
selbstbestimmung ich finde dass dieser
begriff in dieser diskussion teilweise
völlig skurril verwendet wird weil wir
leben in sozialen gemeinschaften und da
ist sind wir weit entfernt davon
selbstbestimmt zu leben die rentnerin
mit 800 euro rente die kann nicht mal
entscheiden selbst bestimmt ob sie
veganerin sein oder nicht weil es sich
bezahlen wenn wir über den tellerrand
deutschlands gucken und sehen wo die
würde verletzt wird ist es ganz anders
also das würdige leben und das
selbstbestimmte wäre ja erst mal schon
mal ein ziel du hast ein ganz wichtigen
punkt bei verantwortung anderen
gegenüber und die wird auch darin
eingetragen zu sagen wenn ich gehe
versuche ich es so angenehm wie möglich
für mein umfeld zu machen weil egal
welche regelung besteht es wird ja
dennoch der suizid im stillen kämmerlein
durchgeführt direktor ist ein acker
zugestimmt also kann es einen schritt
auf ihn zugehen
welche vorteile kann denn da eine legale
organisierte sterbehilfe haben ganz
großer treiber von einem ungesunden
trauerprozess ist schlechtes gewissen
ich kann letzte wünsche nicht erfüllen
und ich weiß nicht wie ich reagieren
würde bei uns ist jetzt einmal nicht auf
arbeit sondern auf mich persönlich wenn
meine oma 85 zu mir sagt erik hier ist
jetzt schluss bitte hilf mir dabei also
entweder lehne ich den wunsch von ihr
abkommen quasi ein realitäts falle oder
ich mache es dann habe ich einen
menschen umgebracht
die situation möchte ich niemanden
bringen und viel wichtiger noch was ich
in meiner arbeit sehe ist der psychische
schaden dem suizide die eben dann die
antwort sind wenn ich keine medizinische
hilfe bekomme in dem maße wie ich sie
brauche was suizid auslöst in der
familie im familiensystem ist ein
immenser schaden ein immenses traumata
hast du denn da ein konkretes beispiel
wo es genau so eine situation gab wohl
gesagt hätte es na ja bei den
angehörigen wäre vielleicht in dem fall
sterbehilfe hätte die ganze situation
das trauern besser gemacht ich hab ich
habe zwei extrem beispiele für mich die
aber er sich durchaus beispielhaft sind
das ist für mich etwas anderes ist und
das machen wir unsere arbeit kinder
darauf vorzubereiten dass ein elternteil
stirbt kann passieren bei einer
krebserkrankung wenn dieses elternteil
aber dann für sich die antwort des
gewalttätigen suizide
gibt ist der schaden bei den kindern
meines einmal
signifikant größer als wenn die
psychologisch betreut auf diesen prozess
vorbereitet sind und das zweite wo ich
selber immer wieder situationen komme
ist
wie häufig menschen bei mir sitzen die
in fauster diagnose haben die mir
relativ deutlich sagen wann sie sterben
werden wo einfach klar ist was schön weg
davor den liegt dass sie das für sich
selber entschieden haben aber die dann
immer damit kämpfen und ich weiß nicht
ob sich jemand an den an den autor von
schicker einer der herren dorf der mit
einer krebsdiagnose beschreibt er sich
das leben nehmen möchte und dessen
größte angst so schieße ich eigentlich
hin um wirklich tot zu sein und es gibt
die suizide du hast die zahlen
vorhergesagt und die werden wir auch
nicht verhindern die frage ist können
wir die in eine bahn lenken dass es für
das umfeld und für den der sich das
leben nimmt
tragbarer wird ich würde gern noch mal
darauf zurückkommen dass du gesagt hast
dass du auch schon momente hattest du
irgendwie ein druck verspürt er den
frage an euch könnte die liberalisierung
der sterbehilfe nicht auch tatsächlich
zu solchen situationen führen dass
menschen zum beispiel alte menschen die
dann irgendwie angst haben dass jeder
familie emotional sowie finanziell zur
last fallen sicher unter druck fühlen
und dann irgendwie denken ja das ist
jetzt ein mittel was daraus führen würde
also ich würde sagen man muss das ganze
prozedere in irgendeiner form
standardisieren wenn man den begriff mal
benutzen darf es kann natürlich nicht
sein dass irgendjemand zu einer
sterbehilfeorganisation geht und sagt so
ich habe die nase voll ich möchte gerne
nächste woche sterben es muss da schon
bestimmte hören geben und der
us-präsident muss natürlich
berücksichtigen dass auf der anderen
seite leute stehen die keinen fehler
machen wollen und jemanden einfach in
den tod schicken das ist eine ganz klare
sache
ich könnte mir vorstellen vielleicht
gibt es auch zum teil keine ahnung dass
man einen fragebogen aus arbeitet mit
viel empathie
patientenorientiert mit ganz großer
feinfühligkeit denen man mit dem
suizidenten durchgeht und zwar in
anwesenheit eines arztes und vielleicht
auch noch einen psychologen eines wunsch
menschen wenn man das will so dass man
wirklich am ende sicher sein kann dass
derjenige eben nicht gedrängt wurde und
ich glaube man kann schon dann gespür
dafür bekommen ob derjenige vielleicht
doch noch lieber leben würde wenn die
umstände denn anders lernen oder eben
sagt nein fragen sie nach gemeint aber
die wäre wie wäre es dann für dich wenn
es einfach also wenn das jetzt einfach
eine normale option wäre würde so ein
test für dich helfen so einen fragebogen
egal ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn
ich jetzt den druck von aussen verspüren
würde das ist zum beispiel bei einer
familie nicht mehr länger zulassen
möchte dann würde ich natürlich den
fragebogen auch genau so ausfüllen ich
bin ja nicht dumm dass ich am ende hält
sich der beihilfe genehmigt bekomme ich
glaube dass dieser druck auch wenn man
eine frage stellt und sagt ja ist da
dieser druck da und es vielleicht auch
psychologisch hinterfragt ich war auch
schon bei einem psychologen gewesen auch
während der ersten therapie muss mir
nicht gut geht denn die haben in diesem
nicht auf den grund zu kommen warum es
mir eigentlich nicht gut ging und so
also ich kann mich natürlich nur rein
schulen in einer situation aber ich habe
sie noch nie erlebt hast du manchmal dem
moment wo du dachtest das ist so scheiße
für meine familie dass die sich gerade
um mich kümmern müssen und ich merke
dass sie darunter leiden dass
tatsächlich also wenn ich ich bin halt
weil der lebensraum ja nicht so ich
würde nie auf die idee kam selbst zu
machen zu wollen aber es ist es war
wirklich teilweise so gerade bei meinen
freunden die abo mit der situation nicht
umgehen konnten als wirklich gedacht
habe ich werde nie war einfach nicht
mehr da
als er sich dann das war für mich weil
die qual auf meine freundin dann zu
sehen die halt
dieses den für die gäste mehr gelitten
als ich und das hat mir mega zu schaffen
immer könnt ihr das irgendwie verstehen
dass das zumindest für ihn persönlich in
solchen momenten nicht gerade das beste
gewesen wäre wenn das standardisierte
das ist auch so sagen das schlimmste was
einem passieren kann also da muss man
doch glaube ich nicht drüber diskutieren
das dann aber es ist nicht realistisch
dass das auch noch viel häufiger
passiert gerade bei alten menschen ja
das ist über diese projektion in die
zukunft die natürlich keiner heute mit
gewissheit beantworten kann oder es war
ja auch im urteil ganz klar zu lesen
dass das gericht gesagt hat sehr wohl
hat der staat die pflicht diese umstände
zu prüfen um eben zu verhindern dass
menschen aus solchen zwängen heraus ich
vielleicht
oder gerade immer auf die altenheime
bezogen gedrängt fühlen würde ich
natürlich aber die frage stellen wie
gehen wir eben mit unseren alten
menschen um was sind das für
rahmenbedingungen von denen wir jetzt
sagen die sind so gravierend dass sie
dazu führen könnten dass hier so eine
art sozialer druck aufgebaut wird ihr
leben im kapitalismus das wissen wir so
ist es nicht auch irgendwie realistisch
wenn man mal so in die zukunft schaut
dass so ein moment passieren könnte das
vielleicht auch der staat sagt neuer
qualität palliativmedizin ist zu teuer
alte menschen gehen eh nicht mehr
arbeiten dann halt sterbehilfe naja ist
das nicht was na klar so reden weil die
kostengünstigste variante das letzte
lebensjahr also unglaublich teuer das
wissen die kassen und nur weil es so
gesagt dass im verfassungsurteil steht
das gegenteil dritten da steht nämlich
dass wenn menschen sagen ich möchte die
mir zur last fallen dass das ein grund
ist der zu akzeptieren ist die jungs
gesagt der staat muss sondern der staat
kann überprüfen frei verantwortlichkeit
dauerhaftigkeit und ernsthaftigkeit
eines suizids tisch und allein bei
freiverantwortlich wird schon schwierig
wie freiverantwortlich bin nicht tagein
tagaus klargemacht wird mein leben ist
nichts mehr wert ich bin ein
kostenfaktor und wenn ich alternativen
nicht weiß dann ist das mit der
verantwortlichkeit nicht so weit
hergeholt das sind alles unklare
begriffe wo tatsächlich eben ich diese
normalisierung und gerade
standardisierung macht mir dann
erschreckt mich daher wenn die leute im
alten hatten ankreuzen mit welchem
status wieder nicht mehr wollen brigitte
ohne dass du einer jetzt in allen
punkten irgendwie zu stimmen was
verstehst du diesen einen punkt
ich kann hier im grunde alle punkte
verstehen aber irgendwie komme ich immer
wieder auf einen punkt zurück
egal die richtig oder falsch das alles
sein mag ein mensch hat das recht für
sich selbst zu entscheiden ich habe für
mich selbst beschlossen ich werde
niemals in ein seniorenheim gehen in
einem pflegeheim denn ich lasse mir
meine freiheit nicht nehmen oder hat
kein mensch irgendwas mit zu reden und
mir das zu versuchen aus zu reden weil
ich würde dann sagen alles gut gemeint
dankeschön aber habe ich keine lust
drauf noch was verstehst du dass ich
kann es verstehen dass man das möchte
aber ich finde es nicht richtig
das spielt aber auch mein christlicher
glaube eine rolle dass ich denke ich als
mensch sollte darüber nicht ein aber das
ist so eine ganz große also eine die das
gerade die kirche oder häufig dieser
beantwortung dieser frage immer noch ein
religiöser hintergrund ist das ist doch
quasi wirklich absurd gerade in
bundesländern wo ich weiß gar nicht der
der anteil der kirche ist sie eine
minderheit dass die da noch mitredet
finde ich eher schwierig also anteil der
tiere ist einfach ich bin nicht in der
kirche und trotzdem bin ich auch den
anteil von religiösen und heute ist die
lehre die mit so vielen leuten partie
über das thema und ich verstehe alle
drei perspektiven was mit dabei fehlt
ist die bestimmung über andere menschen
und das da da kriege ich die bausch mir
ist niemand von uns sechs hier stehen
hat es recht immer zu sagen dein wunsch
zu sterben zählt nicht natürlich habe
ich das recht eben hilfeangebote zu
geben aber
wenn du nicht umsonst sind dass die
suizidrate glaube ich gerade im
medizinbereich relativ hoch wo menschen
arbeiten die wissen wie sachen am ende
ausgehen
und und ich glaube diese gewalt zu
verhindern gegen sich selbst und gegen
seine mitmenschen das ist für mich ein
hauptgrund weswegen ich hier stehe und
sage bitte lasst das zu und lassen uns
nach einem weg suchen wie menschen die
alle möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft haben
friedlich sterben dürfen das ist mir ein
bisschen das prinzip wir werden den
laptop kaputt gehen und man weiß nicht
weg so heutzutage ist es halt so früher
hat man die sache nicht mehr repariert
ist jetzt ganz böse gesagt aber ich bin
schon dass ich das genaue gegenteil von
dem was ich gesagt das ist mittlerweile
ja schon der gedanke nicht genau
ausgeben sollten alle möglichkeiten
ausgeschöpft sind also und natürlich bei
der krebsforschung die die fortschritte
sind im märz natürlich den letzten
jahren ich habe in meiner arbeit als
patienten begleiten dürfen und müssen
und zu sehen wie die wirklich also
selbst mit palliative betreuung ist es
glaube ich zumindest für mich eine
erkrankung die die die viel viel leid
mit sich bringt selbst mit einer guten
medikamentösen einstellung die ersticken
einfach irgendwo an
ich muss euch leider kurz unterbrechen
da würde ich gleich direkt zu dir kommen
benedikt du hast dich nämlich dafür
eingesetzt dass auch ärztinnen erlaubt
wird menschen beim sterben zu helfen
unter welchen voraussetzungen würdest du
das denn bei einem patient oder einer
patientin machen ja ich bin in der
palliativmedizin tätig und das ist
eigentlich ein lebenshilfe verein aber
ich möchte auch nicht mit strafe rechnen
müssen wenn ich in einzelfällen bereit
diesen weg mitzugehen ich werde immer
versuchen patienten die mit einem wunsch
nach sterbehilfe zu mir kommen die
menschen im leben zu halten und sie zu
begleiten und den natürlichen
krankheitsverlauf zuzulassen aber es
gibt situationen in denen kann ich
nachvollziehen was menschen den weg bis
zum ende dieser krankheit nicht
gehen müssen
und ich möchte mich einem solchen wunsch
da nicht verschließen das krad strafbar
gesagt also dass du dich nicht strafbar
machen möchtest und das andere ärztinnen
sich nicht strafbar machen möchten gab
es einmal diese situation was du ein
patient oder die patientin hat es und du
gemerkt hast wenn es jetzt möglich wäre
dann wäre das die bessere möglichkeit
für diese situation gewesen oder der
patient die patientin hat sich das total
gewünscht ich bin ausdrücklich kein
sterbehelfer das ist einfach auf meine
berufliche situation bezogen in der ich
auch unausweichlich
ja weil es ja meine patienten sind mich
damit beschäftigen muss und das würde
ich eben gerne in den
beratungsgesprächen ergebnisoffen machen
können
und wenn ich der auffassung bin dass
heißt eine
wohlerzogene und frei
verantwortete
entscheidung ist eben ohne auch druck
von außen und das können wir glaube ich
beurteilen wenn wir die patienten
betreuen wir kennen dann auch das umfeld
dann für mich zu entscheiden ja das gar
nicht mitgehen man gab es einmal eine
konkrete situation
ja natürlich gab es das und es gab auch
eine situation dass ich jemanden
weggeschickt habe weil ich mir nicht
sicher war wie das weitergeht wie steht
ihr denn zu dem was benedikt hat gerade
gesagt habe bewegt euch das irgendwie
nach vorne oder er hat natürlich recht
aber wäre natürlich ein unrecht wender
wenn er suggeriert dass es verboten sei
oder gewesen wäre auch zu 217 wenn man
die begründung zu dem paragraf gelesen
stand ja eindeutig drin das nachstehende
womit eine ärzte die nahe stehen sind
auch gemeint werden es hat nicht ein
einziges verfahren mit dem von 1705
jahren gegeben und es ist halt doch seit
ist überhaupt auch berufsrecht gibt oder
wie auch immer in deutschland noch nie
ist ein arzt und irgendeiner form
belangt worden wegen unzulässiger formen
der sterbehilfe da gibt es nicht einen
einzigen fallen aber spätestens jetzt
hast du doch alle freiheiten menschen
beim suizid zu begleiten so wie es jeder
andere mensch auch kann eben nicht nur
ärzte die vielleicht auch nicht immer
die richtigen sind um das herauszufinden
ob der sterbewunsch ernsthaft ist aber
du kannst du da sind wir ganz
beieinander und ich habe eben
auch andere informationen und andere
auskünfte dass die zeit 15 bis 20 eben
nicht so gefahrlos gewesen ist oder
gewehre für uns ärzte und natürlich war
es bis 215 straffrei klar ich stimme dir
zu und da geht es nicht auch so ein
bisschen darum ob es eben ein langer
qualvoller tod ist oder ob man sich
davon vielleicht erlösen kann
einem langsamen qualvollen tod den muss
es ohnehin nicht geben da wird schlechte
medizin betrieben unbarmherzige
schlechte und wahrscheinlich
inkompetente medizin denn menschen in
sterbens nachher situation da wird immer
von code erbrechen gesprochen dann wird
von schwerster luftnot gesprochen wenn
man die nicht vernünftig behandelt dann
macht man sich strafbar denn das kann
man das konnte man auch vor zwanzig
dreißig vierzig jahren schon wenn man
sich ein bisschen mit medikamenten
auskennen und auch weiß dass man sehr
hoch dosiert auch medikamente geben darf
die das bewusstsein
zum erlöschen bringen und auch in kauf
nimmt dass die menschen dann eher
sterben aber das ist eben nicht das
problem deswegen ich hier stehe das
problem ist nicht sterben sna und
leidvoll sondern sterbens fern und
leidens frei wenn man redete man so viel
drüber da kann ich den sollte man
möglichst schmerzfrei machen und all so
was ist wenn du sollte viel mehr wert
darauf gelegt werden den zu verhindern
wenn ich weiß dass ich mit meiner
geschichte alleine schon ich kann das
aufzählen wie viele leute schon zu mir
gekommen sind und gesagt haben wegen dir
weil ich sehe dass du doch in einer
schwierigen situation in der lite seine
situation sogar noch glücklich leben
kann deswegen möchte ich mich nicht mehr
umbringen und ist nicht halt richtig
krass wenn ich das höre dann denke ich
dann sind die alten sind
gesetzesentwürfe eigentlich übernehmen
sagt man sollte er mal vielleicht sich
darauf fokussieren wie kann man auch
psychologisch oder eben über den glauben
und wie auch immer neuen selbstmord
abbringen so ich würde nicht abstreiten
dass jetzt das nicht schön ist wenn sich
in zukunft dann kommt von mir arbeitet
bei der bahn ist sollte man auf jeden
fall verhindert werden aber nicht in dem
sinn dass man sagt okay ich gebe dir
nach hause und gäbe in die spitze
sondern dem man das komplette das
problem angeht es ist eine
ursachenbekämpfung in wie ich wenn man
sollte ja das problem angehen
möchte ich mich gerne anschließen weil
ich kenne selbst depression und
angststörungen ich kenne viele andere
betroffene es selbst keine menschen die
durch den suizid gestorben sind und ich
kenne auch selbst sieht gedanken
beziehungsweise auf einen suizidversuch
ich bin gegen die sterbehilfe vor allem
bei psychischen erkrankungen weil ich
überzeugt davon bin dass wir die
möglichkeiten der prävention als auch
der behandlungen noch nicht vollkommen
ausgereizt haben wir sollten viel mehr
energie zeit geld was auch immer in die
prävention und die behandlung von
körperlichen wie auch psychischen
erkrankungen stecken anstatt zu sagen
komm her hier ist geht er einen schritt
auf nora zu sich jetzt ein bisschen am
vertreten hierbei stecken natürlich da
musste doch nicht rüber in den ring
gehen hier da sind wir doch alle bei dir
das wir gravierende defizite haben im
umgang mit kranken im mit wird man nicht
halten im fernsehen sonst was man sieht
ist so wenig so wenig berichtet darüber
sterbehilfe ist ein riesiges thema der
punkt da sich viele auch gar nicht
trauen wenn er nicht mal zum psychologen
zu gehen oder wo auch immer hin zu gehen
diese hilfe zu holen ich finde dass
krieg viel zu wenig aufmerksamkeit also
aber du musst es ergänzend es geht ja es
geht ja weiter also ich spreche aus
medizinischer sicht über angebote werden
alle menschen mit einer mit einer
tödlichen diagnose ein hospiz platz in
deutschland anspruch nehmen würden dann
würden die hospize also die haben jetzt
zumindest in den großen städten überall
wartelisten und dennoch kommt aber immer
wieder auf einen punkt wenn ich ihn
kenne könne er nicht verwendet werden
nicht wenn ich in kenntnis all dieser
punkte ich weiß ich kann ein hospiz
gehen ich weiß ich kann von einem guten
palliativmediziner betreut werden immer
noch sage ich möchte diesen leidensweg
nicht gehen ja die frage es geht immer
um diese gruppe es geht nicht um
menschen wo es verhindert werden kann
weil sie durch einen guten
psychotherapeuten gerettet werden wo man
sich über jeden freut dem ist besser
geht jede geschichte wie deine ist toll
aber es gibt dennoch menschen die
sterben an ihren erkrankungen und wollen
auf diese art und weise nicht sterben
aber er hat ja seine eigenen sterbens
ferner sterbehilfe gerät wenn das
richtig verstanden habe das heißt dass
der tod eigentlich noch gar nicht so nah
ist und man vorher ausscheiden will und
das dann bei mir sind diese diese
gedanken die angst vor dem leid kann oft
größer sein als es leicht selber warum
sagst du denn dass es für dich vorteil
gewesen wäre wenn zu dem zeitpunkt ist
schon möglich gewesen gewesen wäre
sterbehilfe in anspruch zu nehmen
außerdem ganz einfachen grund dass ich
inzwischen zu mir und meinem leben
gefunden habe ich bin glücklich in
meinem leben ich bin stärker aus der
krise heraus getreten
und könnte das alles nicht erleben wenn
ich damals die pille genommen hätte wenn
du dir in anspruch hättest nehmen können
dann hättest du es gemacht auf jeden
fall und ich habe spontan im vorfeld auf
instagram eine community gefragt einfach
mal so mensch wenn ihre frau ein paar
jahren in der depressiven krise die
chance gehabt hättet
assistierten suizid hätte das gemacht
und wenn ihr aber heute noch lebt seid
ihr froh dass es das damals die
möglichkeit noch nicht gab und zwei
drittel der befragten haben gesagt sie
hätten das wahrgenommen sie sind aber
heute froh dass es die möglichkeit nicht
gab und das finde ich wichtig zu sehen
na klar gibt es auch das andere drittel
die gesagt hätten so ja ich hab's
gemacht und ich finde es blöd dass es
damals die möglichkeit noch nicht gab
ich möchte auch ich verurteile keinen
menschen der suizid begeht fans total
falsch wenn das wie früher unter strafe
stünden würde ich finde es aber falsch
dass geschäftsmäßig zu machen könnt ihr
jeder zustimmt verstehen die im punkt
dann könnt ihr einen schritt auf sie
zugehen ja es ist natürlich
die schwerste situation dies zu
beurteilen gilt ob sie frei
verantwortlich ist ob sie wohlüberlegt
ist du sprach von der depressiven krise
wer in der lage ist das zu erkennen
der wird natürlich einen solchen weg
nicht mitgehen und er dürfte ihn auch
nicht mitgehen
weil wir die frei verantwortung brauchen
das wohl überlegt und die nachhaltigkeit
und ich weiß nicht ob man da
grundsätzlich sagen darf nein psychische
diagnose ist schließt
suizid assistenz aus auch da gibt es
einen leidensweg
ständig medikamente einzunehmen und
trotzdem würde ich mal wieder
einzubrechen ich würde gerne dazu sagen
ich hatte nicht eine einmalige
depressive krise sondern kennt männer
sind kindheit ich war mehrmals in
ambulanter therapie in tageskliniken
mehrmals in der psychiatrie ich habe
verschiedene antidepressiva genommen ich
bin seit vier jahren stabil ich bin
jetzt 36 mit ca 32 jahren hatte ich so
für mich den weg aber seit meiner
kindheit kenne ich die symptomatiken
dazu auch generalisierte angststörung
mit panikattacken es gibt phasen in
meinem leben da konnte ich nicht alleine
einkaufen gehen s bahn fahren oder was
auch immer wann war auf die
unterstützung meines partners oder eben
freund einen drauf angewiesen gerade zum
beispiel jetzt sagst du bist du vier
jahre lang stabil er würde es ja von dir
behaupten dass du in der lage bist
freiverantwortlich einen willen zu
formulieren ja
und dann hättest du die möglichkeit dann
doch diesen schritt zu gehen
um vielleicht nicht in weitere krisen zu
gelangen wie ich das bewährte dass ich
da auch massivste bauschmerzen bei hätte
ist völlig unbenommen aber die
rechtslage ist nun mal so dass man das
dann dürfte und ich glaube eben nicht
dass man aufgrund deiner psychiatrischen
diagnosen dir dieses recht vorenthalten
sollte man sich ein krasser aussagen
wonach das ist jetzt mal auf deutsch
gesagt du solltest du jetzt entscheiden
kann nur weil du eventuell wieder
absicht also der personen betrieben kann
ist also ist jetzt umbringen die
veranlagung laden also ich hatte die bcv
rezidivierender zu gut kann man auch
komisch sein veranlagung depressionen
und ich weiß dass ich gefährdet denn das
ist besonders auf mich achten muss wenn
es einen becher schicksalschläge gibt
sag ich mal
aber jetzt entscheiden so argument in
drei jahren könnte wieder eine krise
kommen und ach nee ich sag mal lieber
sterbe lieber gleich bekommen wir da hin
wenn wir so handeln das finde ich
einfach total unethisch brigitte
verstehst du diesen einen punkt ich
denke bei depressiven noch mal eine
andere sache wie man da sicherstellen
kann dass es eine wirkliche entscheidung
von ihnen heraus ist und dass er
zurechnungsfähig ist also das ist das
ist anders als wenn jemand wirklich aus
dem innersten heraus
zurechnungsfähig entscheidet ich möchte
nicht mehr leben also bringt kann ich
denke wer der da psychische probleme hat
den muss man schon mehr beschützen sage
ich mal so also dem würde ich jetzt
nicht für nächste woche einen termin
geben und sagen okay wir machen das dann
könntet ihr eigentlich ein schritt auf
sie zugehen weil ich glaube er ist das
auch so ich weiß nicht ich war glaube
ich finde es schwierig das für
psychische krankheiten anders bewerten
als körperliche weil wir sagen dann
können sie nicht mehr entscheiden
psychisch kranker darf auch zu einer
operation einwilligen also ich finde es
eben name ist bei dir ich finde es
schwierig das zu unterscheiden und ich
finde auch dass wir menschen mit
psychischen erkrankung nicht recht
absprechen dürfen die andere haben also
das merkt man ja wenn ich sage meinen
sohn hatten hüft-op dann gucken nicht
alle an und haben mitleid wenn du sagst
ja da aber eine psychische erkrankung
dann ist die stimmung erst mal anders
also wir gehen gesellschaftlich mit
psychischen erkrankung fürchterlich um
indem und deswegen glaube ich können wir
da keine unterschiede machen was denkt
ihr denn sollten auch menschen mit
psychischen erkrankungen sterbehilfe in
anspruch nehmen können oder er nicht
bekommen jetzt der kompromiss runde
damit ihr bestenfalls gleich alle hier
steht unterricht in einigen punkten
einig sein und gemeinsam lösungen findet
ich habe jetzt erst mal einen
lösungsvorschlag für euch können wir uns
darauf einigen dass wie offizielle und
vom staat kontrollierte beratungsstellen
brauchen die mithilfe von bzw ärztinnen
psychologinnen sozialarbeiterinnen
entscheiden wer beihilfe zum suizid
neben darf und wer nicht wenn er sagt ja
dann könnte er jetzt einen schritt auf
mich zukommen
hier habe ich gar nicht bewegt
weil ich weiß das ist eigentlich gar
nicht die frage sein sollte ob diese
option da ist auch immer wieder gehört
dieser punkt
dass es schlimm ist bei angehörigen
suizid mitzuerleben ich glaube dass halt
genauso diese schuldgefühle auch da sein
kann wenn das selbstbestimmt passiert
und ich glaube dass man da irgendwie
etwas zieht ist einfach keine lösung
dann habt ihr jetzt die möglichkeit euch
gegenseitig noch mal zu überzeugen weil
das ja hier ein bisschen das ziel ihr
könnt euch jetzt jeweils beide seiten
für einen benutzer die köpfe
zusammenstecken und überlegen was wäre
einen vorschlag einen lösungsvorschlag
für für euch beide
grund seien entsprechende hilfe verein
wende das habe leute dass das habe ich
von analysieren diskussion wird gut und
schlecht okay wir haben jetzt nach
dieser diskussion gemerkt das ist gar
nicht so einfach dieses ganze thema und
sterbehilfe zu lösen also falls ihr
jetzt ein kompromissvorschlag hat denn
ihr gerne hier genau jetzt vorschlagen
würde dann schreibt es keine kommentare
ja das klingt hervorragend weil die
anfangen hat ja ein lösungsvorschlag
bisschen schwierig ja also zumindest
erstmal es ist ein ansatz zu einer
lösung zu kommen wenn wir von dass wir
eine diskussion eine breite
gesellschaftliche diskussion von
kindergarten über arbeitsplatz besonders
wohin brauchen zu diesem themen ohne
diese polarität in die religiös
vernagelten und die wild absurd
freiheits denkt nicht dass wir von dem
schwarzweiß wegkommen müssen um zu einem
weg zu kommen jeder zustimmen ich würde
zustimmen dass wir sagen
niemand der mit der thematik verbunden
ist und der angesprochen wird hat auch
den wunsch dass dieser sterbewunsch sich
realisiert sondern dass wir natürlich
alle
zwar vielleicht ergebnisoffen aber doch
von der intention her das ziel haben
dass der mensch dich nicht umbringt das
ist doch glaube ich konsens für an aber
dann könnte er eigentlich alles wirklich
alles immer so gern dass das niemand
will du nicht und keiner hier aber es
gibt auch andere leute die das hat ja
was macht zu tun andere zu tod zu führen
das sind ja auch alles leute die
psychologisch nicht mal selber hilfe
branche hat also das sind jetzt keine
größenordnung über die man sich jetzt
gedanken machen muss ich glaube eine
stärke von vereinigungen damit habe ich
auch meine schwierigkeiten ist sollte
eine gute und natürlich auch kostenlose
möglichkeit geben und niedrigschwellige
möglichkeit geben sich beratung zu holen
auf ganz vielen ebenen es ist einfach
schlagen
kann es noch nicht so verkürzen jetzt
auf eine minute jetzt dann ein
riesenproblem dass wir jetzt mit einem
klaren urteil mit einem weitreichenden
urteil haben jetzt in die praxis
umzusetzen das geht einfach in diesen 12
minuten jetzt so nicht ja aber ich denke
uns verbindet habe ich die intention das
dass wir möglichst das versuchen die
menschen im leben zu halten und das
würde ich auf jeden fall zustimmen dann
könnte er einen schritt aufeinander zu
gehen
ich glaube es ist mir ganz ist eine viel
größere sache es muss etwas viel
größeres eingebunden sein und das haben
wir ja kurz angesprochen
ausbau der hospize beratung etc
die gesellschaft muss auch lernen anders
mit dem tod umzugehen ähnlich jetzt
immer nur als feind anzuschauen sondern
als baustein des lebens als letzten
baustein des lebens der das leben dann
abrundet der den kreislauf des lebens
schließt er da stimme ich voll so also
gerade in der jungen generation auch
dass so wenig über den tod überhaupt
nachgedacht wird und dann wenn es eben
mal so weit ist dann muss man ganz
schnell eine entscheidung treffen oder
sowas und sich da bewusst zu sein so
jeder tag könnte der letzte sein auch
heute wir wissen es ja nicht genau und
am ende hat man es eben nicht in der
hand in manchen fällen kann man es
vielleicht sagen aber das finde ich
schön dann wissen der gesellschaft auch
bisschen thematisiert wird und ja da
einfach offen darüber diskutiert wird
minister nicht heute verschwinden genau
ich auch ich danke euch auf jeden fall
für die diskussion ich habe mich sehr
gefreut es war sehr spannend danke euch
ja was
was soll man sagen nach so einer
diskussion also ich glaube wir alle
haben heute nochmal gelernt wie
emotional und sensibel und auch
individuell dieses thema ist und gerade
durch diese individuellen persönlichen
geschichten merkt man auch noch mal wie
schwer es ist wirklich eine regelung
dafür in der zukunft zu finden weil eben
bei jedem die probleme und die
geschichte anders ist haben euch
argumente überzeugt vielleicht denkt er
jetzt sogar anders über das thema ist
nicht selten so bei 310 fragen dann
schreibt es gerne in die kommentare
und ansonsten das gerne ein abo das
könnte hier machen hier oben findet ihr
ein weiteres video von 13 tragen und
hier ein weiteres video zum thema